ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูพจน์
สวัสดีค่ะครูผู้หญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เรียนนักเรียนของร้อยค่ะนักเรียน
นะคะรู้ซะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันพุธโอเคค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 25 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565  a  Call ศ.อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะวิ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันสุดวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
27 เดือนอะไรให้เงินหรือสภาคมปีพตอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าเฮ้ยเฮ้ยตอน
นี้เวลา
11:00 น 11 โมงกี่นาที
11:03 ค่ะ
[เพลง]
3 นาทีนะ 11:03 เป็นเวทย์เอา
เป็นเวลากลางวันแล้วกลางวันแล้วเย้
วัน
ไข่สบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะค่ะครูฟ้าสบายดี
ไหมคะครูฟ้าสบายดีค่ะครูหญิงสบายดีมากๆ
อันนี้หน้าครูหญิงผู้ใหญ่จังใหญ่สัตว์
อันนี้ครูหญิงหรอคะๆค่ะหน้าขลุ่ยหมุนยิ้ม
มากๆเลยค่ะครูฟ้า
ทำไมครูหญิงยิ้มมากๆคะ
คุณต้องเขียนชื่อเมื่อฉันด้วยคะก็จะได้
รู้ว่าครูหญิงผู้หญิงมีคิวนะคะนักเรียนจะ
ว่าทำไมเราไม่ได้จะสอนคิ้วถึงว่าคิ้วนิด
หน่อยนะฮะ Q ทำไมผู้หญิงผู้หญิงยิ้มใช่
ไหมผู้หญิงยิ้มเพราะอะไรอ้าวก็กูหญิงดี
ความสุขในครูฟ้ากูหญิงยิ้มมากๆเพราะว่า
เดือนหน้าดีเดือน
มิคุณย้อนคุณนายพูดภาษาไทยสิคะ
มิถุนายนรูหญิงเนี่ยจะไปที่เที่ยว
มีทิปส์เย้
เย่นขาผู้หญิงจะไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
ผู้หญิงจะไปเที่ยวผู้หญิงขอลบหน้ากูหญิง
ก่อนได้ไหมคะนักเรียนได้ก็แดกอาหาร
นี้เนี่ยก็จะไปเที่ยว
วิมลสนุปปี้เนาะแต่ว่าเหมือนม้าน้ำเฟตไทย
นี้กำลังประเทศไทยไงอันนี้บ้านครูหญิง
สมัยจากประเทศไทยเด็กผู้หญิงก็จะไป
ขอโทษคนมีไงนะคะ
อะไรอ่ะชนนะคะแต่
อันนี้เหมือน 4  Host เลยอ่ะ
[เพลง]
อันนี้คือประเทศไทยค่ะอันนี้น้องเพศอะไร
ส่วนรูปนี้เนี่ยอเมริกาค่ะนักเรียนบอกว่า
ทำไมอเมริกาเล็กกว่าประเทศไทยผู้หญิง
นาฬิกาเล็กจังได้ขอโทษแก่ผู้หญิงบ้านใหม่
ก็ได้ค่ะไม่มีการเนี่ยใหญ่ใช่มั้ยนัก
เรียนนาฬิกาใหญ่นะประเทศไทยก็ใหญ่โว้ย
นี้นะคะใหญ่จะไปไหมในอินพ่อไหมคะอเมริกา
ใหญ่มาก
นี่ไงผู้หญิงก็จะไป
ไปเที่ยวอเมริกาค่ะครูฟ้า
ไปเที่ยวไม่มีกา
ไวแล้วผู้หญิงก็จะไปอเมริกา
เมืองอะไร
เมือง
อยู่ตรงไหนไม่รู้นะคะ
วอชิงตัน
นิวยอร์กค่ะครูฟ้าอยู่โอ้ย new  york ค่ะ
คนไทยพูดอยู่ย่อย new  york นะคะผู้หญิง
จะไปเดือนหน้าหรอไม่ความ
เย็นไฟฟ้าไปด้วยได้ไหมไม่ได้
ทำไมเอ้าไปอเมริกาเนี่ยก็ต้องมีวีซ่า
ถ้าเธอไม่ใช่ Visa  Card นะคะมีซ่า
อเมริกาแล้วก็ไปอเมริกาเนี่ยไม่ได้ขับรถ
ไป
แล้วไปยังไง
ต้องนั่งเครื่องบินนี่มึงไม่
บาดหน้าเงินเครื่องบิน
ใต้ค่ะมันต้องนั่งเครื่องบินไป
ใช่ไหมต้องซื้อตั๋วเครื่องบิน
[เพลง]
ลบออกลบพบ
ๆนะฮะนั่งเครื่องบินค่ะนี่อันนี้คือ
เครื่องบิน
นะคะครูฟ้าคะ
อันนี้ของเครื่องบินเราเรียกอะไรคะอีก
ปีกแล้วนี้ของเครื่องบินเราเรียกอะไรคะ
หางถึง
มาแล้วตรงนี้นะคะที่กูหญิงกำลังวาดอยู่
เนี่ยเราเรียกอะไรคะหน้าต่าง
โอ้ยต้องตบมือทำไมแล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่า
เครื่องบินมีล้อไหมมีมีอยู่ตรงไหนอยู่
ข้างในคงไม่เห็นใช่มั้ยอยู่ข้างในนี่นั่น
แล้วเนาะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคยบัตรลบผิดนะ
ขอโทษจะเคยนั่งเครื่องบินใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
หรอเฮ้ยเคย 5 คู่ฟ้าเนี่ยเคยนั่งเครื่อง
บิน
[เพลง]
มากินมั้ย
ฟ้านั่งเครื่องบินแต่ว่าข้างในนะดีอ่ะกู
คู่ฟ้าเคยนั่งเครื่องบินแล้วก็เลยจะมีคำ
ถาม
มี 3 คู่ฟ้า
ถามว่าอะไรคะ
พูดใกล้ขนาดนั้นก็ได้เอาเครื่องบินเนี่ย
นะคะคะเวลาเรานั่งเนี่ยมันก็จะมีคุยจะวาด
ได้ไหมอ่ะ
ได้สิทำไมจะไม่ได้
หรือจะว่าแล้วนักเรียนจะเข้าใจไหมครูบา
ยังไม่เข้าใจเลย
อย่าเพิ่งถามนักเรียน
ที่ว่าตอนนี้ผู้หญิงกำลังว่าอะไรอยู่คะซี
เอา a ขอ
เก้าอี้หานักเรียนนะเนี่ยบอกว่าผู้ฟ้า
อยู่พูดภาษาอังกฤษนักเรียนฟังไม่เข้าใจ
อ่ะเขาก็จะมีเก้าอี้ใช่ไหมคะ
บางบางครั้งก็จะมีเก้าอี้ 1  2 เนาะ 2
ตัว
บางครั้งก็มี 3 สมัยนี้เรานั่งแบบธรรมดา
นะเราไม่ได้นั่ง business  class  V  NET
ก็คือชั้นธุรกิจฉันมันจะ the  first
class  First
First  Class เนี่ยนี่แพงกี่บาท
ค่าไปอเมริกาผู้หญิงคิดว่าน่าจะ
เป็นแสนเนาะ
โอ้โหนี่โดนล่าเหรออ๋อบาทค่ะแต่ว่าอาจจะ
เป็นแบบอ่ะเอาคู่ยังไม่รู้นะเพราะว่าไม่
เคยนั่งแล้วนักเรียนอาจจะ
20,000 บาทเป็นแสนสั้น
เป็นแสนแสนเลยหรออันนี้คือไปอเมริกาใช่
ไหมทรายค่ะหรือว่า 5 บางครั้งไม่มี first
class  first  class ภาษาไทยไม่มีนะคะ
นักเรียนคนไทยพูดเฟิร์สคลาสนะคะแต่ว่ามัน
อาจจะมีเป็นชั้นธุรกิจใช่ไหมฉันธุรกิจ
เนี่ยอันนี้ก็แพงก็จะแหลนเหมือนกัน
ก็เป็นแสนไปอเมริกา
นี้ก็เป็นแสนวิชั้นธุรกิจก็คือแบบเก้าอี้
สมัยเก้าอี้ตรงนี้ก็ยืดได้ตังค์ไหนนะคะ
เมื่อวานพี่กูหญิงวาดรูปเนี่ยอันนี้เป็น
ชั้นประหยัดในเป็นชั้นรยาศก็คือ
คือสามชัยค่ะก็เป็นแค่หมื่นใช่ไหมเป็น
หมื่นบาทนะคะหมื่นบาทเพราะว่าลิ้นครูหญิง
นั่งได้รูฟ้านั่งได้ทุกคนโอเคไม่แพงถ้า
ฉันธุรกิจหรือว่าชั้นเฟิร์สคลาสนี่อันนี้
แพงมากๆนะต้องเป็นแบบอีลอน Mask นาหาเบล
เกตโอเค
ครูฟ้าฉันธุรกิจชั้นระยะตนั้นคนไทยพูด
ชั้นประหยัดแต่ครูหญิงตัวเตี้ยนั่งชั้น
ประหยัด
บ่ตายสบาย
แล้วฟ้าล่ะคะก็โอเคจ้าแต่ธาตุสูงมั้ย
สูงแต่ขาไม่ยาวเลยนะฮะ
180  cm นั่งชั้นประหยัดโอเคไหมอันนี้ก็
อาจจะแบบเมื่อยขานิดหน่อยไหมเพราะฉัน
ประหยัดและตัวนี้ก็จะมีเก้าอี้อีก 1 แถว
ใช่ไหมเก้าอี้
ที่แบบมันจะใกล้ๆกันใช่ไหมคะขาเนี่ยขาก็
อาจจะแบบไม่โอเคแต่ครูหญิง
[เพลง]
150  cm สบายนะคะเหมือนฉันธุรกิจเลยค่ะ
นั่งสบาย
โอ้โหดีมากค่ะหญิงน่ารักเสมอแอบถ่ายผู้
หญิงก็เลยไป
เอ่อชั้นประหยัดใช่มั้ย Economic อายหัน
ไปอย่างประหยัดนะชั้นประหยัดก็จะเป็น 3
ใช่ไหม 3 แล้วก็จะมีตรงนี้เราเรียกว่า
เป็นทางเดินอะมีทางเดินแล้วก็จะมี 1  1  2
3 มีเก้าอี้ 3 ตัว
อัดชนิดเป็น 4 แล้วค่ะครูฟ้าหงอเก้าอี้ 4
ตัวมันก็ 3 ใช่ไหม 4  4  5  6  7 แต่ก็จะ
เป็นทางเดินนะคะแล้วก็จะ
มีเก้าอี้กี่ตัวคะมีเก้าอี้อีก 3 ตัว
[เพลง]
โอ้
เสร็จแล้วก็ 8  9  10 ใช่ไหมครับตรงนี้
เนี่ยก็จะเป็นหน้าต่างอันนี้ก็จะมี
หน้าต่างแล้วของเครื่องบินนะคะ
นักเรียนมองภาพให้มาเป็นแบบหน้าต่างน็อค
ผู้หญิงก็ว่าเป็นแอ๊บแสบได้อีกหรออันนี้
ก็จะเป็นก่อนเมลตอนแม่อ่ะนะแต่ไม่ใช่พี่
นาวนั้น
พาเราก็จะบอกว่าเป็น 3 ใช่ไหม
ออนไลน์ค่ะคือผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็จะถามครูฟ้า
ว่าเวลาฟ้านั่งเครื่องบินครูฟาสก็ชอบนั่ง
ตรงไหน
ใกล้หน้าต่างติดติดหน้าต่างหรือว่าติดทาง
เดินชะเยติดหน้าต่างดีติดทางเดิน
เอ่อครูฟ้าชอบนั่งติดหน้าต่าง
มีข่าวค่ะครูหญิงแป๊บนึง
ติดหน้าต่างต่อแบบหนึ่งหรือว่าตรงนี้ก็
ได้ใช่ไหมสิบ
ใช่หรือตรงนี้ก็ได้อันนี้กูไฟล์ชอบนั่ง
ครูฟ้าค่าครูฟ้านั่งเครื่องบิน 16
ชั่วโมง
ทำไม 16 ชั่วโมงกูฟ้านั่งติดหน้าต่างไฟ
ฟ้าในเครื่องบิน 16 ชั่วโมงก็ต้องกิน
อาหารดีได้น้ำดื่มน้ำ 16 ชั่วโมงเนี่ยออก
ปวดฉี่
ฟ้าไม่ค่อยเข้าห้องน้ำ
มะพร้าวไม่ชอบห้องน้ำแล้วนักเรียน
หรออ๋อห้องน้ำอันนี้ใช่ไหมห้องน้ำเนี่ยขอ
ถ้าครูฟ้านั่งเครื่องบิน
26 ชั่วโมงกริ่งฟ้าบวชชีกุมภาเกาะ
โอเค
ฟ้าไม่เข้าห้องน้ำออกไม่เข้าห้องน้ำแต่
จริงๆปวดฉี่ก็บอกได้ใช่ไหมถ้ามีมีครูฟ้า
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วถ้าตรงนี้เนาะตรงนี้มีคนนั่ง
ตรงนี้มีคนนั่งไหมกูฟ้าก็บอกได้ว่าขอโทษ
นะคะไปห้องน้ำ
อันถ้าไม่ใช่คนไทยก็ต้องพูดภาษาอังกฤษ
เช่น Sorry ขอโทษนะคะ
x  q จะมีเอ่อก็ช่างเขานะคะภาษาอังกฤษ
ใช่ไหมตอบภาษาไทยก็ขอโทษนะคะขอไปห้องน้ำ
ขอใบห้องน้ำถ้านักเรียนนั่งติดหน้าต่าง
แล้วข้างๆสมัยทางๆตรงนี้เป็นคนไทยนัก
เรียนอยากพูดภาษาไทยกันขอโทษนะคะผู้หญิง
พูดนะคะ
ผู้ชายขอโทษนะครับขอโทษนะครับนายเขาเข้า
ใจเลยค่ะพูดแค่นี้เขาเข้าใจอ้อห้องน้ำบน
เครื่องบินมาเลยก็
ขอโทษนะครับก็ใช้มือ
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าชอบนั่งติดริมริมหน้าต่าง
เนาะไปใช่ควายชอบนั่งติด
หน้าต่าง
ใกล้ๆเพราะผู้ชายชอบดูวิวไงนั่งติด
หน้าต่างเนี่ยก็คือจะมีวิวว่าก็จะดู You
Who  will ก้อนเมฆเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะก็เอก
วันแม่เอาอย่างนี้ไหมมันก็จะเป็นก้อนเมฆ
ก้อนแม่ก็เน่ก็จะดูอันนี้ประเทศไทยอัน
นั้นลาวเวียดนามอะไรนะใจไม่เข้าใจเรื่อง
บินน่ะ School สูงมากๆๆ
แต่ว่าไม่ได้สูงขนาดนั้นแต่ว่าไม่ได้สุข
ขณะที่จะเห็นเป็น
ไม่ใช่นาซ่านะคะอาจจะไม่ฉันไม่เห็นประเทศ
ไทยหรอไม่เห็นไม่เห็นให้กดผิดนั่นแหละว่า
ก็ชอบนั่งติดหน้าต่างแล้วครูหญิงหรอคะผู้
หญิงชอบนั่งติดหน้าต่างหรือนั่งตรงกลาง
ตั้งเตือนฉันให้
นั่งเองอันนี้ก็นั่งตรงกลางก็ได้นะเพราะ
ว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบนั่งติดทางเดินนั่งติด
ทางเดินคือตรงไหนอันไหนครูใหญ่ตายแต่ว่า
ตรงนั่งทางเดินเนี่ยมันก็จะมีตรงนี้ใช่
ไหมคะ
1412 ที่เป็นตรงกลางแล้วก็ 3 แล้วมันจะ
มีริมริมแล้วก็สองเนี่ยตรงกลางผู้หญิง
เนี่ยชอบนั่งติดทางเดินตรงกลางค่ะครูฟ้า
อันนี้เป็นผู้หญิงนะคุณเหลืองนะคะได้ค่ะ
ในคะลบก่อนลบก่อนค่ะมินิผู้หญิงสั้นนั่ง
ตรงนี้เลยผู้หญิงตัวเตี้ยนะคะ
มัน Baby
เสื้อและครูหญิงตรงนี้ก็ได้ราคานักเรียน
นั่งแถวที่ 4 หรือ
ตรงนี้
โอเคผู้หญิงชอบนั่งติดทางเดินตรงนี้เป็น
ทางเดินใช่มั้ยแอร์โฮสเตสเนี่ยจะเดินหา
ซ่อมนั่งติดทางเดินโรงกลาง
ทำไม
ผู้หญิงชอบไปห้องน้ำที
แต่เราก็ไม่ชอบพูดบ่ขอโทษนะคะไปห้องน้ำกล
ไทยรู้สึกแบบถ้าครูหญิงน่ะไม่ใช่ถ้ากู
หญิง
สมมติว่าผู้หญิงนั่งที่นี่
ที่ไหนเราเคารพก่อนนะคะอ่าอันนี้เวอร์ 4
ใช่ไหมถ้าครูไม่ติดหน้าต่าง
พรุ่งนี้และผู้หญิงปวดฉี่ใช่ไหมคะตรงนี้
ก็จะมีคนนั่งมีคนนั่งผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ชอบ
พูดขอโทษนะคะห้องน้ำรู้สึก
เองมิสเตอร์เอ
บิสเตอบีนเนี่ยกำลังนอนหรือว่าดู
พูดพูดโอเคไม่โอเค
มันก็เลยไปสอบแล้วก็เลยคิดโอเค
นั่งติดเส้นทางเดินมาติดทางเดินตรงนี้
เวลาปวดฉี่อยากไปห้องน้ำก็ลุกแล้วก็เดิน
ได้ก็ถ้ามีถ้ามีคนนั่งใช่ไหมมีคนนั่งตรง
นี้มันก็มี Choice  a กับ B ผู้หญิงก็ลุก
1 ครั้งถ้าคนนี้คิดห้องน้ำแล้วก็เลยชอบ
นั่งติดทางเดินนะคะ
แต่ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนชอบนั่งเครื่องบิน
ตรงไหนเหมือนครูฟ้าใช่ไหมนั่งติดติด
หน้าต่างหรือว่าเหมือนครูหญิงนั่งติดทาง
เดินนะหรือตรงไหนก็ได้
ก็ให้สลิลได้เอ่อไม่ได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้
เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนเนาะแล้วอารอนเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ